JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
Wait, don't eat that.
MARCO GUIDOBALDI: Why not?
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: It's rotten.
MARCO GUIDOBALDI: Oh,
I guess you're right.
I bought it today, but I didn't
really check every single apple
in the bag.
It's such a lot of work to
make sure all apples are good.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: It can be,
unless you can get some help
from machine learning.
MARCO GUIDOBALDI: Ah.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON:
With AutoML Vision,
you can train a visual
recognition model quickly
and easily, using
your own pictures,
so you can better automate
this kind of thing.
Look.
[BUZZER]
See?
It's 100% rotten.
MARCO GUIDOBALDI:
Wow, this makes
quality control look so easy.
Can you show me how it's done?
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Sure thing.
[WHIRRING OF THE LOGO]
[THEME MUSIC]
I built this web
app using a model
trained on pictures of fruit.
Since we've trained it on a
data set of good and bad apples,
when I take a picture
of a new apple,
it's able to accurately figure
out if it's good or bad,
like I did for your apple.
The model clearly
recognized it as bad.
MARCO GUIDOBALDI:
That is really cool.
How would I build one myself?
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Let me
show you how it's done.
It all starts in the
Google Cloud console.
First things first, we need
data to train the model on.
Here, we've got a Google Cloud
Storage bucket full of images.
The images are divided into
rotten and fresh folders.
I've created a
CSV that lists all
of the images and their labels.
I've used a quick
script to do that,
as there are
thousands of images,
but you can use the AutoML
interface to do this manually.
Let's take a look at
the interface now.
Here, we need to
create a data set.
It's really easy.
Go to New Data Set,
give it a name,
choose how you want to
import your images--
in our case, I'm just going
to point it at the CSV--
and then hit Create.
It will import them from GCS.
This may take a few minutes.
Now that we have all the
images imported and labeled,
we can train the model on them.
AutoML takes care of
splitting the data set
for training, validation,
and testing, so you
don't have to worry about that.
Just hit Start Training and let
Google Cloud handle the rest.
This can take anywhere from
15 minutes to several hours,
depending on the
size of the data set,
so let's switch to a model
that's already trained.
Once you have
trained your model,
you can test the prediction
right here in the interface.
Just upload a picture
and look at the result.
There is an API
endpoint, too, and that's
what I link my app to.
Simple-- no service to
manage, no code to train.
MARCO GUIDOBALDI:
That is fantastic.
Now, I can easily train my own
visual models for apples, food,
or just about anything else.
JUSTIN GRAYSTON: Exactly.
If you like this
demo, don't forget
to subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[WHIRRING OF THE LOGO]
[THEME MUSIC]